vous êtes né comme moi dans ce pays ni
serions-nous pas nés que nous
l'aimerions si nous devions y
travailler nous nous sentons je me sens
si profondément raciné dans la vie de
notre pays que l'indépendance pour moi
c'est quelque chose d'aussi simple que
ma façon de respirer il n'est pas
possible que la France puisse se
soumettre aux injonctions de quelque
pays que ce soit
seraitce notre
plus fidèle et notre meilleur allié mais
l'indépendance ça se défend ça se défend
avec la monnaie ça se défend avec le
travail défend avec une armée ça se
défend avec une économie qui échappe à
la puissance des sociétés apatrides des
sociétés
multinationales cela n'est pas défendu
aujourd'hui c'est ma tâche pour demain
je crois à l'Europe monsieur cardestin
et contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
le programme commun respecte le marché
commun vous n'avez pas fait l'Europe
sociale vous n'avez pas fait l'Europe
régionale vous n'avez pas fait l'Europe
monétaire vous navez pas fait l'Europe
des peuples cela reste à faire c'est ma
mission